You've been writing essays wrong all
along and it's thanks to one of the
worst pieces of writing advice.
>> That's right for yourself. What is the
single worst piece of writing advice
that you often hear?
>> I I think it's it's the very common know
your reader.
>> Write about whatever you're interested
in. Here's where that advice fails. It
only works from the writer's
perspective. I mean, think about it like
this. We writers use writing as an
extension of our thinking. We open up a
blank document to work out a problem and
the solution only comes at the end. But
if we stop there, then we ship something
that readers can't use. So write about
whatever you're interested in is the
writer's definition. It ignores the
reader's perspective altogether. So in
this video, I'm going to give you the
reader's definition. One that's simple
enough to write on a post-it note and
useful enough to refer to every time you
sit down to write. And here it is. An
essay helps readers understand something
better that they want to understand.
Well, now let's break that down. For
your essay to work, it must help
specific readers, but many writers act
like the particulars don't matter. They
say, "I don't know my reader yet. I'm
just getting my ideas down." Or, "It
doesn't matter who reads it." And this
kills your essay from the start. Here's
why. Readers expect your essay to answer
certain kinds of questions. For example,
if you want to solve a crime, well, you
don't write an essay. You examine
evidence and you make a case about who
done it. What's called an argument of
fact. You write it in a report or a
briefing, not an essay. But if you want
to work out the meaning of art or decide
the right course of action or argue that
one politician should be the president
over another, then you're out of the
world of facts and into the world of
values. These are arguments of judgment
and these are what your reader is
expecting to find in your essay. Essays
deal with questions of good, bad, right,
wrong, better, and worse. And unlike
facts, this kind of knowledge isn't
objective. It doesn't exist out there in
some metaphysical sense. It exists only
by consensus within a particular group
of people. So, if the kind of questions
that we deal with in essays are socially
constructed, then getting clear on your
reader isn't something you do after you
write. Your reader is not icing on the
cake. They're the batter. The structure
of your argument, the conventions, the
word choice, the references. It all
flows downstream from your particular
reading community. So, if you want to
write a valuable essay, you need to ask
valuable to whom? Now, some of you are
already convinced about writing for
specific readers, but you don't want to
box yourself in. You want to be
multidisciplinary, writing across two or
more audiences, and that's fine. But
this is like playing several games of
chess at once. It doesn't absolve you
from thinking about the particulars of
each game. It just means that you need
to think about multiple particularities
at once. Now, for the second part of our
definition, what if I told you that
everything you've been taught about the
purpose of essays is wrong? Because it
is. If you go by what most writing
manuals say, well, they say that the
goal of an essay is persuasion. But
that's wrong. The goal of an essay is to
help readers understand. Think about it
like this. An essay is a genre, and all
genres exist to help their users get
things done. which means that every
genre has a goal, a function. So for
example, the purpose of a white paper is
to persuade stakeholders to adopt a
certain position. The function of these
genres is to persuade readers to act.
And before you object, it is true that
some writers do both. They improve
understanding and they drive action, but
the action comes second. And if you go
chasing after the rabbit of action, then
you risk failing to meet the primary
function of your essay, which is to
improve your reader's understanding. And
for the third part of our definition of
an essay, what would you say if I told
you that I was quitting my job as an
English professor to become an inventor?
My invention, the world's first coaster
camera lens. So when you're filming, you
can use it to prop up a cold beverage.
And whenever you're done, you can just
pop it on the lens and voila, a new
product. Well, you'd probably say,
"Don't quit your day job, professor."
But the way you are looking at me right
now, like I've lost my mind and embarked
on some insane project that'll never
work. That's exactly how I look at
writers when they tell me what they want
to write about. Because many writers
want to write about what they want to
think about. They don't want to adapt to
what other people want to think about.
And look, I know that you don't want to
hear this, but here it is anyway. You
have to write about what your readers
are interested in understanding. Now,
look, I'm not talking about audience
capture here. You're not about to become
some slave to market demand or reader
interests. And there are ways that you
can shift your reader interest. There
are certain techniques that we can talk
about, but we can't talk about shifting
reader interests until we address the
biggest thing holding writers back, and
that is self-centeredness. A lot of you
are possessed by a vision of your
favorite writer who, despite everyone's
advice, persisted in writing about
whatever interested them. They were
passionate, stubborn, committed to their
own inspiration. Readers be damned. And
over time, enthusiastic readers found
them. If you build it, they will come.
And so with that vision, you want to do
your own original research. Key word
there is original. But writers who start
this way always hit the same wall. They
think that anything original counts as
research. So if an idea hasn't been
written about before, it must be
valuable. Right? Wrong. So if you think
that original ideas are automatically
valuable, then you are imagining
knowledge as a fixed puzzle with missing
pieces. add a new piece and the value is
obvious. And to be honest, that works
for arguments of fact. So, for example,
if you're examining a crime scene and
you bring in some new evidence, well,
that evidence is automatically valuable.
But again, in essays, we are not dealing
with arguments of fact. We're dealing
with arguments of judgment. So, your
idea is not like a missing puzzle piece.
It's more of an invention that you're
taking to the market. And so if
consumers can understand it and they can
use it to solve a problem, then they'll
adopt it and reward you. And if not,
then it stays on the shelf. And the same
thing is true of your readers. If they
can understand your idea and they find
it useful, they'll adopt it and share it
and they'll reward you. But if they
don't see how it solves a problem that
they care about, it stays dead on the
page. In other words, your idea only
becomes knowledge when readers accept
it. But just because you say something
new doesn't mean that it's valuable or
even true. It only gains value when
readers accept it as true. So I mean
just think about the declining rates of
reading around the world. And then ask
yourself how much interest do you have
to spare. Your readers do not even
remotely want to spend their time
reading about anything you're interested
in. Now, yes, a great writer can shift
what a community cares about, but that
skill is rare, difficult, and pretty
risky. Your essay succeeds when its
topic aligns with something that readers
already want to understand well.
Sometimes, a good essay can make readers
care about something new. But in the
vast majority of cases, essays succeed
when they advance understanding of
something that their readers already
care about. Something is not anything
and readers are not you. And for the
fourth part of our definition of an
essay, readers decide what counts as
better understanding, not writers. Now,
notice what this definition requires.
You need to know what counts as better.
You can think of your essay like a set
of directions. If your goal is to take
the reader somewhere farther, you need
to know their starting position. You
can't give good directions without
knowing where somebody is standing right
now. And the same thing is true of
essays. To help readers understand
something better, you need to know what
do they already understand? What do they
want to understand? Where are the gaps
in their knowledge? And this is why you
cannot be agnostic about your reader and
write well. Your essay is only good if
it helps them understand something
better. So the degree to which you help
your reader depends entirely on how well
you know them. They're the ones who
decide whether your piece helped them
understand something better. So your job
is to know them well enough to meet them
where they are. And for the fifth part
of our definition, helping readers
understand requires methods, not just
good intentions. And before becoming an
English professor, I studied meditation
with a Buddhist monk. And he had a
definition of love that I absolutely
love, which is that love is the ability
to help someone suffer less. And when he
provided that definition, he really
honed in on that word ability. Because
you might recognize that someone else is
suffering and you might have the
intention to help them. But if you don't
have the ability to help them suffer
less, your intention is beside the
point. You can actually harm them with
your intervention. And the same thing is
true of writing. It's not enough to
intend to help readers understand
something better. There's a specific
skill set that you need to actually be
able to help them. And that skill set is
argument. Arguments are how we introduce
new ideas. And every argument has three
parts. So first there's a claim, which
is a falsifiable statement about the way
that things are or the way that they
should be. Falsifiable means that
somebody else could disagree with it. So
the sentence water is wet is not a claim
because nobody could possibly doubt it.
It's just a definition. It's
automatically true. But the sentence
water is better than Gatorade for
hydration is a claim because somebody
somewhere could object. And the second
piece of an argument is evidence because
readers won't just accept your claim on
its face. They want proof. And the key
is knowing what kind of evidence your
reader will accept as credible. Some
readers want citations from authorities
in the field or primary sources. Others
will be convinced with a well-chosen
anecdote. So what matters is that the
evidence is something that the reader
will find credible. And the third part
is a warrant. You could think of it kind
of like a reason, but it's more like a
logical bridge connecting your evidence
to your claim. Evidence doesn't speak
for itself. Two writers can look at the
same piece of evidence and reach
opposite conclusions. You see this in
climate science. Researchers might
accept that temperatures are rising, but
they develop different explanations to
support different claims. So, claim,
evidence, warrant. Master these three
elements and you'll have the ability and
not just the intention to help your
readers understand something better. But
to do that, you need to understand how
readers actually read. what's happening
in their minds as they move through your
sentences. Now, most writers fall back
on lists of writing rules. But I think
there's a better approach, reader
psychology, because when you understand
what's happening in the reader's mind,
you can adapt your pros to fit how they
naturally process your writing. So,
watch this video next because it's going
to show you four proven writing
principles based on reader psychology.
Principles that will help you turn that
definition into actual essays that work.
So, be sure to go check it out.
[Music]